elliot page took to his instagram today
to let his followers know
they are transgender elliot addressed
his fans with a personal post
saying quote hi friends i want to share
with you that i am trans my pronouns are
he they and my name is elliot i feel
lucky to be writing this
to be here to have arrived at this place
in my life
i feel overwhelmed with gratitude for
the incredible people who have supported
me
along this journey in the post eliot
also describes himself as non-binary
which means their gender identity
is not male nor female elliot continued
the post by saying quote i love that i
am trans
and i love that i am queer and the more
i hold myself close and fully embrace
who i am the more i dream the more my
heart grows and the more i thrive
to all the trans people who deal with
harassment self-loathing
abuse and the threat of violence every
day i see you
i love you and i will do everything i
can to change this world for the better
elliot is right there is more work to be
done just recently
laverne cox took to her instagram to
share that she and a friend
during an outing in los angeles were
victims of a transphobic attack
the guy who had asked for the time says
to my friend
guy or girl my friend said
off i'm walking i'm hearing all this is
happening like in a split second
and then all of a sudden the guy is
attacking my friend
and elliot's wife emma portner shared
this message of support on her instagram
saying i'm so proud of elliot page trans
queer and non-binary people are a gift
to this world
i also ask for patience and privacy but
that you join me in the permanent
support of trans life every single day
elliot's existence is a gift in and of
itself shine on sweet e
i love you so much and celebrity friends
like tegan and sarah also showed support
on twitter
saying profound love and admiration for
you your strength bravery and activism
not to mention all the art you
contribute to this earth is truly
special
thank you for being so open about your
journey and for fighting
so hard to make the world a better place
i couldn't agree more
thank you elliot for all you have done
and continue to do for the queer
community
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos